here's kevin newman that was a pretty
good day
yesterday and some ground balls in this
first inning from suitor gobbled up by
sogard and that is quick work more
ground ball outs in the first five here
for suitor
will face jacob stallings and not
messing around
sooner gets the strike out of stalin's
station of stations for the first three
on
base is loaded nobody out omar narvaez
coming up now
brewers with a chance to do some damage
here he struck him out
kept going with that high fastball and
there's one out
now jace peterson number eight hitter
well we're going to see we'll get one
out there and that's it
bases remain loaded a heck of a job of
pitching he gets out of this jam
grace has loaded nobody out you don't
often come out unscathed he's a strike
away from doing it
trevor williams trying to pitch out of
it here it is
swinging a bouncer hit bobbled and the
throw
off target and the brewers are going to
get a couple of runs
kevin newman had that one on one hop and
bobbled it
and then threw badly to first and the
crew gets two
pirates look to get a run or two on the
board right here in the third
finally get a base runner against brent
suter
eric gonzalez at the plate roped to left
get up
all right bob euchre i like that call
that's a line drive home run
for eric gonzalez get out of here and
gone
that's right he tied it up and the look
of disgust
from brent suter so it's up to ben gamel
he's singled and scored back in the
second
yelich at third they got a pretty good
clip now
over these last nine plus games and that
will continue with an rbi
single to center that'll get yellow chin
and the brewers regain the lead yeah
what a nice approach right there
two out base hit the score run
[Music]
outstanding work all three of the
brewers runs have come with two outs
first and second nobody out for eric
sogart here's the pitch
and a line drive toward left field
that's trouble back is frazier makes a
fine over the shoulder catch
and back to the bases narvaez to second
peterson to first
one two pitch ground ball right side
moran goes to second for one on to first
and it gets by the pitcher
here comes narvaez to the plate he's
going to score
the brewers add another run of what will
be a throwing error
by the shortstop eric gonzalez brings up
adam fraser
tucker at second with two outs they're
trailing 4-2
as frazier grounds this fair inside the
first base bag
tucker will score frazier as the ball
kicks off
the short fence out there as it juts out
toward right he'll hold it first with an
rbi
single and it's a 4-3 game boy what a
swing that is
i don't know if it's raining outside now
or not it's a beautiful night inside
miller park
it always is coming back swinging in a
rocket to center deep and going to be
off the wall out there
and it is gone for castanera
that one hit right above the uh the
fence out there that yellow line and
bounced back into the field of play
and kesten hero has just hit his eighth
of the year
here's gregory polanco he's up for two
second and third one out down a pair
for one two and that'll cost him strike
three
he offers up every pitch exactly where
you want it you can see narvaez setting
up
high in the strike zone two minute round
now and jose ozuna is the batter
breaking ball lined into center for a
base hit
moran is in stalling's trying too
and he gets in there it's a two out two
run single for jose osuna
the pirates tie it at five looking for
one or two more clutch hits for craig
council to talk about
in the post game 5-5
deadlock here at the ballpark breaking
ball hit in the air
toward the corner that is down to base
hit gamble stays hot
he's on his way to second with a double
the lead off the eight
uh he hangs right in there and that
breaking pitch right there lefty versus
lefty that's a big hit
chance to break this tie in the eighth
inning set the table for hater
for 2-2 on the ground and throw
into left field at base hit here comes
gamble here's the threat of the play
it's cut off as the brewers take the
lead
orlando garcia a run scoring
single yep got the slider that he got
the other night
this time a single into left boy orlando
just continues to put together good at
bats
and it's a full count hater versus
frazier
payoff pitch slider game over
struck him out looking as hater strikes
out the side of the ninth
and the brewers take three out of four